there's a corner of Georgia being torn
to pieces by wild hog but they've picked
the wrong patch
soldiers
[Music]
[Music]
hog is lean tender and bursting with
flavor to give me the chance of tasting
some delicious prime Kutz from the wild
I'm joining the army special task force
under the command of major Bobby toon
[Music]
gonna see now how difficult are these
hogs big fast furious very fast and
delicious they're very yeah they taste
very good freeport can't beat it Charles
is a catchin one the chances of us
seeing one and encountering picks
tomorrow I would say it's probably 80 to
85% the chances of you being able to
close the deal are you calling this
shitshow I'm just saying that's why
we're here tonight to make sure and
everything goes proper absolutely to
keep the hog population down there's a
forty dollar reward for any shot on the
base I'll be aiming for mine with a
powerful long-range rifle
yes settle your crosshairs yeah exhale
so difficult yep
that's a money shot you see it yeah bang
guns are used for protection and to kill
any hogs in traps but there were alien
to me
and it showed tomorrow morning yeah
we'll stick with the long rifle yeah
definitely
sold the pistol
we started our search the following day
at 6:00 a.m. as go hunt for pig the
first lesson was how to track the pigs
through the forest is that this is pigs
get right there pig [ __ ] I'm trying to
use the biological name but you're
correct sir that would be [ __ ]
it's the hop damage here that's led to
the Army's decision to kill them in
order to stop the numbers from spiraling
out of control
you can see where the pigs they dig in
the sand how many time there's been
almost like a bomb it's like a forehead
yes I can't believe how much damage they
caused it they eat all the nutrients to
eat all the bugs eat all the roots and
all the tubers out of the ground having
walked four kilometers it was getting
harder to keep a sense of direction but
signs of a pig trail kept a confidence
high you see this this these places
where there's mud yeah that's from a pig
not smart I mean how smell Pig and the
pigs came across this Creek and you can
smell that yeah so that's it sauce
coming against the tree I was gonna tell
you that but you're correct yes yeah
that's the pigs yeah derriere rubbing
it's a tree two hours in and still
nothing the Hogs always seen one step
ahead but then
[Music]
[Music]
but they were too quick for a camera and
the sights of my rifle
[Music]
walk out
there's a pig inside there right
yeah christ almighty a hog caught by one
of major toons traps was in the road
ahead I haven't got to be looking at it
but yeah he's a he's a big pig he does
not look happy nope
we'll just shoot him and
then we'll have to move back to the
truck get the truck load him up and then
go through the whole process of
preparing him to eat when we get to the
cage and that pig gets out of the cage
our drill will be we'll just jump up on
top of the cage
trapping is a harsh reality but a clean
shot close-up will ensure a humane kill
and the Hogs meat won't be spoiled by
any stray bullets twice the size of it
this is [ __ ] nerve-wracking haina a
pig's natural instinct is to charge you
but we just got to stay calm
Jesus Christ
[Applause]
having dispatched the pig we need to
clean it down in the creek before I
learn for the first time how to butcher
it in the wild open him up more to get
his internal organs out so you can
actually start right there it's piping
hot though
you're doing terrific try to keep blade
up so that we don't yeah puncture this
that's the blood that's his bladder and
we don't want that thing to pot so we
didn't taint any of the meat that's
right and this here for his organs
with the innards out we hind the Hawks
carcass from a tree to skin it you know
what you have in your hand right there
Gordon mmm that's uh that's one of his
testicles right here yeah that's a
delicacy with a lot of folks really
Mountain oyster so they cool yeah got
the skin is so tough yeah it is it takes
30 minutes of careful cuts to remove the
skin from the fat that's my bullet can I
have that back that did it
that way
and with the skin off it becomes
recognizable you did it as a mountain of
amazing cuts of meat
shoulder
that's Phillip
chefs delight I'm amazed how dark it is
next the tenderloin and the Hogs ribs
the ribs one of the cheapest but one of
the most delicious
here's the hands good work great work
two hands two loins two ribs two
shoulders we just need to find some
hungry people now yeah somebody wants to
eat some ham that's something we differ
on this campanella' won't be
right hog shot hung skinned butchered
the ribs the loin and it's amazing that
will fill it here I'm punching the ribs
in a fragrant stock onions cloves garlic
and chili a really nice color a large
tablespoon of tomato puree as that cooks
starts to tenderize the ribs boil for 20
minutes this is the loin that is the
rolls-royce of a hog that's the little
philip tender delicious he's actually
that raw having removed the skin slice
the tenderloin and the fill it into
medallions
I'm making a marinade for the meat with
olive oil salt pepper lime juice and
chili powder the marinade will tenderize
the hog to me like eating butter next to
barbecue sauce for the ribs
start off by
the onion and add molasses mass is a
really nice sort of dark sugar syrup I
give the body to the barbecue sauce a
couple of tablespoons of mustard chili
sauces and cider vinegar when you sat
down not too rich without there is the
right consistency rush the meat with the
barbecue sauce then grill
literally 3540 seconds on the line one
hour two minutes on the ribs
whilst the meat rests a coleslaw not too
much mayonnaise nothing worse than a
cold spot you can't identify what's in
here grain mustard coleslaw a nice slice
of loin couple of beautiful ribs through
that most amazing hog grips with a
barbecue Lauren already now some hungry
tummies where are you guys
[Applause]
are we good we're gonna dig in dig it
very good very good very good as I say
in the UK put more pork on your fork
yeah outstanding
we could get hypothermia if we stay down
too long so we've got to be quick but
that's easier said than done